le plus grand dinosaure du monde est une
arnaque visant à rendre son découvreur
célèbre 1877 c'est la guerre des eaux
entre COP et mars deux paléontologues
qui jouaient à qui a la plus grosse
c'est là que KOB décrit en ficellias
fragilimus 60 mètres de long deux fois
la taille d'une baleine bleue mais il y
a un problème le premier c'est que comme
bah sa description sur une seule
vertèbre incomplète en plus de ça qu'il
est le seul à avoir vu et dessiner le
second c'est la méthode de calcul il se
base sur le diplodocus et constate que
sa vertèbres est deux fois plus grosse
donc il double la taille totale du
nouveau Dino 25 mètres x 260 m à temps
quoi toutes ces approximations juste
pour un concours de Kiki entre
paléontologue pour que finalement on se
rend compte que